bertrand et osant d'en louer de trois
mois il sera dans les rues de lisbonne
il a déjà déboursé les 3500 $ demandés
par une agence de voyages qui organise
son séjour au portugal
mais un mois plus tard en passant par
son agence de voyage en car de lui donne
des sueurs froides
très inquiet il essaie de joindre son
agent un message enregistré puis
confirment que le commerce a fait
faillite
bertrand est dans tous ses états fini le
voyage en voler son argent
il ya quand même une bonne nouvelle pour
bertrand il pourra récupérer son argent
auprès du fonds d'indemnisation des
clients des agents de voyages
sauf qu'il devra oublier son voyage il
pourra après la date du voyage remplir
une demande de remboursement au fond
pour récupérer les 3500 dans la prairie
mais attention ce fonds ne rembourse que
les clients qui font affaire avec un
agent de voyages possédant un permis de
l'office de la protection du
consommateur
si vous réservez vous même un vol ou un
hôtel sur le web de fonds ne pourra rien
pour le fin mot de l'histoire
pour aller vite on le fait soi même mais
si vous visez la sécurité et penser à
une agence